great so uh welcome to the second uh
second class
before we start uh I want to go over
just a couple more Logistics
um as a reminder the optional homework
zero is due on Monday next week
we also have a pytorch review session
tomorrow uh I accidentally said that it
was at 4 pm on the first lecture it's at
6 PM it should say 6 PM everywhere and
that's going to be over zoom and you can
find the information uh about it on um
on canvas
we also posted the guidelines for the
project uh this they should be fairly
comprehensive and answer almost all your
questions about the project uh but of
course if you have any more questions
about the project guidelines feel free
to either go to
um office hours or in any of the ti
office hours essentially or you could
also make a post on Ed about it as well
we also have exciting news about Cloud
credits so uh we were able to get
sponsorship from Microsoft Azure to
provide us Cloud credits and assuming
the enrollment doesn't change too much
we'll be able to give everyone around a
hundred dollars in Cloud credits for
completing homework one homework two and
the project if you'd like it uh homework
one and homework two are going to use a
GPU and so that's especially why we're
going to provide the credits because not
everyone has access to gpus already and
we're going to provide a guide for
getting started on Azure and so forth
and we'll provide that all on Monday
which is when homework one is coming out
great and then office hours also start
today
um for instructor office hours uh those
are going to be in person and they're
just in Packard 202 right after
Wednesday lecture
um we're going to post more information
about office hours as well um about
signing up for the pre-scheduled office
hours and so forth on Ed in the next uh
day or so
great any logistical questions before we
start with technical content
awesome okay so the plan for today is to
talk primarily about multitask learning
and we'll talk about the problem
statement the model the objective the
optimization process different
challenges that arise and then we'll
also go through a case study of kind of
a real world example of multitask
learning then if we have time we'll also
cover transfer learning as well
um I suspect that we probably won't get
to transfer learning and we'll just
cover it in a future lecture
uh and so the goals of by the end of the
lecture are to be able to try to
understand really the key design choices
when designing multitask Learning
Systems also be able to understand if we
get to transfer learning to be able to
understand the differences between
multitask learning and transfer learning
and the basics of transfer learning
great
um so let's start with multitask
learning so first of all I'm going to
introduce some notation so that we can
all get on the same page with respect to
the notation that we'll be using and
this will be consistent throughout the
course not just for this lecture
so we'll consider
uh deep networks in this course here's
an example of a deep Network we're going
to consider the input to the network to
be X the label to be y sometimes it will
overload the notation of Y to also mean
the predicted label
so for example maybe one we want to be
able to classify an image as being a
tiger or or a tiger cat or a Lynx or and
so forth
X could also be a piece of text like it
could be the title of a paper and maybe
you want to predict the length of the
paper
and we will use
um Theta to denote the parameters of the
neural network
so this all should all be fairly
standard and in most places we'll use f
to denote the function represented by
the neural network and it will be
representing a probability over the
label space given an input X
okay so this um this is the notational
setup and then in single task learning
in single task supervised learning we'll
be given a data set with X Y pairs
and we want to be able to minimize the
some loss function over that data set as
a function of the model parameters
so a typical loss function might be
something like negative log likelihood
where we want to be minimizing the
negative log likelihood of the labels
given the inputs and this means that we
want our model to be able to match the
labels be able to predict the labels
given the um
given the infosex
okay so this should all be review for
the most part or just getting on the
same page with respect to notation
now what do I mean by a task
so last lecture I gave an informal
definition of what a task is and now
we'll go over a more of a formal
definition
so the intuition is that a task will
correspond to a machine learning problem
and the way that I'll formally Define it
will be I a essentially it'll correspond
to this Tuple right here
which has a distribution of over x a
distribution over y given X and a loss
function
and essentially each of these these two
distributions P are the distribution
that generates the data
and the reason why it's helpful to
define a task like this as something
that generates the data as well as a
loss function over that data is it means
that we can sample corresponding data
sets from that uh from those
distributions so we can sample a
training data set and a test set and
we'll assume that the trading set and
the test set are sampled IID or
independently from these two
distributions
and I'm also going to use kind of di as
shorthand for Di train for the training
data set
okay um and if this is a little bit
confusing you could also just think of a
task as Simply Having the training data
set in the test set and the loss
function
um it's helpful to think about it as the
underlying uh distribution in the sense
that it allows you to sample these these
data sets and uh potentially sample
multiple data sets including potentially
a validation data set for example
okay so that's what I'm going to Define
as a task
now
uh what do different what are different
multitask problems going to look like
uh they could look like a few different
things so one example could be a
multitask classification problem where
the loss function might be the same
across different tasks for example it
might correspond to the Cross entropy
loss function
but
um essentially the data generating
distributions will be different across
the tasks so as an example maybe you
want to be able to recognize
um
handwriting from different languages
and then you're still going to be using
cross entropy loss function in each of
these cases but just the distribution
over X and the distribution over Y is
going to be different because they're
going to correspond to different kinds
of characters and different kinds of
languages
um as another example maybe you want to
build a spam filter and you want to be
personalized for different people
different people naturally receive
different emails they also naturally
have a different distribution over
labels I'm spam for me might be not spam
for you or vice versa and so this is
another example where the loss function
will probably be the same it'll probably
just be cross entropy for example but
the distribution over X and the
distribution over the labels is going to
be different for different tasks
as another example maybe the loss
function and the distribution over X is
going to be identical for the tasks but
you'll have different a different label
space for different tasks
so for example say you want to be able
to look at an image and be able to
detect whether or not the person has
blue eyes or brown eyes or detect their
hair color or something like that then
the just the images are going to be the
same you're going to have the same
training data set but you'll have
different label spaces and your goal is
to basically be able to predict those
different labels and this is what's
called multi-label classification
or multi-label learning
scene understanding is another example
of this where you have a data set of
different scenes and you might want to
be able to predict the depth from that
scene or key points from that scene or
Surface normals for that scene
okay and then there's also examples
where maybe the loss function varies
across tasks as well
um so you might have tasks that have
some tasks that have discrete labels and
some tasks that have continuous labels
and then you might have different loss
functions that correspond to those
different kinds of labels and also
um maybe you're in a scenario where you
care about multiple different kinds of
metrics and uh and you want to be able
to optimize all of those metrics
sometimes this is referred to as
multi-objective optimization
okay any questions on on what a task is
and what multitask learning problems
look like
okay
it's great
so
we want to be able to learn to optimize
and solve multitask learning problems
and one thing that's super important in
these problems is to be able to actually
have some sort of
descriptor that indicates what the task
is yeah
should be able to be complaints among
the prosperous
yeah so the question is um if we have
different loss functions across
different tasks are we still going to
assume that they can be combined in some
way into a single objective
um so we'll talk a little bit about
forming the effective of these problems
later in the lecture but the short
answer is yes and we're going to assume
that each of these loss functions follow
the typical signature of a loss function
and that they're going to be outputting
a scalar value that you want to minimize
and this means that it's usually fairly
straightforward to combine them by for
example by summing the loss functions or
something like that
right so the question is um should they
map to the same output space and um
I guess that that's a little bit more
complicated they could potentially map
to different spaces and then you might
want to weight them in different ways um
wait one loss function higher than
another loss function if it if it is
basically on a different scale for
example
good question
okay so uh typically you'll have for
some form of task descriptor and this
will essentially tell the model what
task it's supposed to be doing what task
is supposed to be solving sometimes the
task will just be fairly obvious from
the input X for example if you're trying
to recognize characters in different
languages you might be able to detect
the language from the character itself
and then you don't even need a test
descriptor but essentially you'll want
to be able to have a description of the
task and pass this into the network in
addition to passing in the input X
and so now the function that we're going
to be trying to learn is not F of Y
given X but F of Y given X comma this
task descriptor
um so uh for example maybe you are given
a title of a paper and you want to
predict the length of the paper but
maybe you also want to produce a summary
of the paper or uh maybe your a PhD
student and you're you're getting a lot
of review requests and you also want to
train a network to actually review the
paper for you as well rather than
actually having to read the paper
so these might be examples of different
tasks and then the task descriptor might
be something like a one hot encoding of
the task index so you could give it a
index of zero if you want the length of
the paper an index of one if you want a
summary of the paper or an index of two
if you want a review of the paper
um or if you have some metadata about
the different kinds of tasks that you
want to solve then you can provide that
sort of information into the network
so
if you want to essentially have
different tasks correspond to different
people different users then you could
pass in different attributes or
different features of those users into
the network
you can also pass in a language
description of the task and this is
fairly common in a lot of NLP examples
where you could say give me a review of
the paper or give me a summary of the
paper or just tldr for example and this
is often referred to as prompting in the
NLP literature
yeah great question so um the question
is can you actually learn this task
descriptor as well in the process can
you tweak it and maybe you could
actually get something better than a
better language description of the task
for example
um in the standard multitask learning
scenario we will not be considering
learning this we'll just be fixing it
but actually as you start to learn these
kinds of task descriptors you're moving
a lot more towards a meta learning
scenario and we'll talk about those in
in the future lectures
cool I mean another example of what this
task encoding could be is like a formal
specification of the task
okay and then once you have once you set
up your model and you're conditioning it
on your task descriptor then at that
point uh you're essentially ready to
to optimize and run multitask learning
and the vanilla objective looks
something like this where the um
where the you're just kind of summing
over your different loss functions so
you take the loss functions for all of
your tasks you have capital t-tasks and
you you sum them and then optimize your
parameters over the sum of the loss
functions
and then from here we actually have a
pretty large design space for solving
these problems so we can decide
different kinds of model architectures
and different ways of conditioning on Z
we can decide do we want to actually
change the subjective this is the most
vanilla objective that we can consider
but there are other ways other
objectives that we could consider and
then we also need to decide how we want
to optimize it you could run a variant
of stochastic gradient descent but there
are also other ways that you can
consider optimizing it as well
so um the model is is like thinking
about how we should condition on z um
and also thinking about what objectives
we should use
um and then ultimately what what how
much we should optimize that objective
okay so
um in the bulk of this lecture we'll
talk about these three design choices
but this will be kind of the overall
setup of the problem
any questions on the overall setup
yeah
sorry can you repeat that
right so the question is what do I mean
by condition on Z essentially what I
mean is just passing Z into the network
uh and so instead of just passing an X
into the network you're going to pass in
both x and z
um so by conditioning I just mean
passing it into the model or more
formally conditioning the probability
the distribution given by the network uh
not just on X but also on Z
obviously
yeah so essentially the vanilla setup is
just a concatenate x and z and then
optimize uh your your objective
yep exactly so you can add add a feature
to your input which is z um you can
optimize it it does turn out that
oftentimes just concatening them and
optimizing doesn't work that well for a
number of reasons and we'll we'll talk
about uh why it doesn't work well and
how we can mitigate it
yeah
information
as possible
yeah so the question is for different
tasks so you have different output
spaces and
um yes and so that will essentially come
into the the modeling design choices and
you can essentially for example have
different heads of the network output
different different outputs based off of
um based off of Z or you could have it
be something that's like a recurrent
neural network that iteratively outputs
different things and decides how much
how many dimensions to use based off of
the the task descriptor
in the back so it's a bit dangerous
formulated I was just curious
right so the question is
um do you does the multitask problem
help with spurious correlations help
help the model be more robust to
spurious correlations by
um
by nature of essentially having some
tasks maybe you don't have that spurious
correlation and other tests do
um
there isn't any work that formally
studies this but
um
the
I guess one thing that I will we
actually have some ongoing research that
studies something along these lines and
we actually find that
um it doesn't make it more robust
essentially uh the network sort of often
oftentimes the network will specialize
for different things and if one task has
various correlations it will
like essentially
pay attention to those various
correlations even if it shouldn't be
yeah
so foreign
case
um like
in in several lectures but um
essentially you can think about
different reinforcement learning tasks
as different mdps with potentially
different Dynamics different reward
functions sometimes also different state
spaces and action spaces depending on
the problem setup
okay
um so let's move on so we have these
three different design choices
uh and we're gonna go through each of
these uh in sequence and we'll start
with uh the modeling choice
so we need to be able to condition on
the task we need to be able to pass this
input the task descriptor
and uh for the time being let's just
assume that this task descriptor is a
one hot Vector meaning that for example
if you have two tasks you just encode
those two tasks using vectors that look
like this that are just like
representing the
um
representing the integers corresponding
to those task identifiers
now
I have a question for you which is that
say that it's the task say that you have
something like this maybe you just have
two tasks and you are representing the
two tasks with this one hot task uh
identifier
how should you go about passing as input
this task identifier if you want to
share as little as possible between the
two Networks
yeah
yeah
exactly so you could
um
you could essentially have kind of
multiple neural networks I'm not great
at drawing neural networks quickly but
you could have multiple neural networks
and then essentially just index into
those neural networks
um with these two functions and that
will share essentially nothing between
the two tasks
any other ideas to add yeah
representations
to embed this into a vector
representation
and then pass that into the network
yeah so you could definitely do
something like that and essentially if
you and actually if you pass this into a
linear Network or a linear layer it will
naturally do that already but if you
pass it into the network and then pass
it as input X then the following layers
will still be shared between the two
tasks and so if you want to share as
little as possible you can do something
closer to what was suggested earlier
where you have kind of essentially two
separate parts of the model and just
index into those two separate parts of
the model using the task identifier
um so kind of visually what that might
look like is something like this if you
have key tasks
um you could essentially have t sub
networks for each of those tasks and
then gate the output of those networks
with your one hot task identifier to
produce the label
and so this is essentially identical to
just training the tasks independently
but the reason why I bring this up is
that it's useful to understand that
there are kind of these two extremes and
one of the extremes is where you are
essentially just doing independent
training and if you do use a formal
multiplicative gating the network could
actually choose to share very little
between the two tasks or between all the
tasks
was there a question yeah
yeah
[Music]
exactly so so
um we're essentially taking the input
password into all these sub networks and
then just taking the output that
um that indexes into the task of course
this is computational it doesn't make
any sense because
um you're doing like T times more
computation than what you need to do
um it's more of a thought exercise than
something that you would actually do in
practice
okay so this is essentially a way to do
like independent training of tests
within a single model
um and one thing that you can note is
even though this is a single Network you
can do this sort of as a single Network
learning all the tasks there isn't any
shared parameters there aren't any
parameters that are shared between the
two tasks in the sense that if these
have completely separate weights then
the weights that are being used to solve
one task are completely different than
the weights that are beings that are
completely disjoint from the weights
that are being used to solve another
task
okay
great and then
um there's also the Other Extreme so
that's one extreme which is that you're
sharing nothing between the two tasks
and um
The Other Extreme is something where you
essentially just concatenate uh Z into
the network at some point and if you do
something like this especially if you
concatenate Z towards the end then
you're going to be sharing all of the
weights between the different tasks
um and so what I mean by this is you can
essentially just concatenate Z with one
of your the intermediate layers of your
network
and yeah to get the prediction you're
running
just running the forward pass through
this network
yeah
this solution would kind of collapse to
the previous one right like if the
networks are still learning like it's
just separate ways to you based on the
index yeah that's a good question if you
do give this a large enough Network
um in principle it could represent the
function that was on the previous slide
it would need to learn that and that
wouldn't be the most natural solution
for it to learn but um but it can still
represent that
um so essentially here are all the
parameters are here yeah
so the question is what if different P
of x's have different modalities for
example like maybe one toss is over text
one task is over images and in that case
you can essentially form a network that
takes its input kind of has two legs of
the Network that has two encoders for
those different modalities and then at
some point combines them together
um that might be a scenario where the
tests are very different and you don't
get a lot of benefit from putting them
together but at the same time it is
something that you could do if the tasks
are it could be helpful if the tests are
sufficiently related yeah
so this is yeah this is training all the
tasks in one network
foreign
great um so I guess one side note is
that all the parameters are shared
except for the parameters that are
directly following z
um but this is
um somewhat of a not a super important
point
okay
um so
that was essentially one view on the
architecture of multitask learning where
you have these kind of two extremes
where you're sharing all the parameters
or sharing none of the parameters
um another way to view this is to split
the parameters into shared parameters
and pass specific parameters
and then our objective looks something
like this where you have these both side
parameters and the top specific
parameters and you're trying to optimize
the sum of the loss functions where
um of course the the loss function for
one task will only affect the shared
parameters and the parameters for that
task and won't affect task specific
parameters for other tasks
and this is uh this is a pretty
important uh thing to think about
because if you do actually put
everything into the same network then
that means that the loss function is
affecting the shared parameters
um for all of the tasks whereas if you
do put them in completely separate
networks then the optimization ends up
looking very different because there
aren't any shared parameters
okay and then from this standpoint uh
choosing how to condition on Z
can be viewed as essentially being
equivalent to choosing how and where to
share parameters
and so if you
if you condition on Z as like the gating
and in the very first example then that
means you're sharing none of the
parameters whereas if you condition on
it later that means that you're sharing
many more of the parameters and you'll
have this more of a joint optimization
rather than an independent optimization
okay
um so that's essentially some of the the
basics of this sort of model
architecture choices and and and so
forth
um now I'll just go through some common
choices that people use in practice when
actually trying to train these multitask
Networks
and so one common choice is to
concatenate like we saw before
and what this looks like is you have
some input
um these can be activations or something
like that or it could just be the input
itself you concatenate with you
concatenate that input with the task
representation Z
and then you pass the rest through
um through your neural network
yep
so you're wondering if some
architectures kind of flexibly assign
shared parameters
yeah so the you can have networks that
essentially dynamically choose which
parameters to share and which parameters
not to share for the purposes of this
slide I consider any shared parameters
as ones that are being optimized jointly
from the very beginning of training
um and oftentimes if you do have these
decisions of like what to share versus
not what to share in the network and so
forth it often has a somewhat similar
effect as sharing all of them because
the network can implicitly choose to
choose even if you put everything in a
single Network it can implicitly choose
to represent things independently
so it often has to do with the
optimization standpoint like the the
optimization problem and so forth but
you can certainly there's actually a
pretty huge design space here in terms
of how how you condition and how you
share parameters
foreign
approach that people use fairly
frequently
another approach is to condition in an
added additive fashion
and uh the way this works is you
take your conditioning representation
pass it through a linear layer to get an
embedding of that task representation
and then add that to
the input to get the um the the next
representation and you can then pass the
output into a neural network and so
forth
now these are two choices and one thing
that you might notice is that these two
choices are actually equivalent
um can anyone tell me why these are
equivalent
um
okay so exactly um what this looks like
is you have a say you have x and z if
you concatenate them into a single
vector and then you pass them through a
linear layer like this
uh say that this linear layer is broken
up into
two halves with two weights then this is
equivalent to
W1 times X Plus W2 times Z and this is
additive conditioning and this is
concatenation
um so they aren't exactly equivalent if
you um you basically just have to break
this weight Matrix into these two uh
weight matrices to see that
um from this standpoint you can see the
equivalence
um and here's a
on the slide here's a diagram that also
illustrates that where W is broken up
into these two matrices and then when
you do the Matrix multiply you get these
two components and then you add them two
together to get this equation question
possible
yeah um there definitely are our
algorithms that do that I'm not going to
cover them in this lecture but um the
the question the person asking the
question can ask that on Ed and I'm
happy to give them pointers
um you're asking W2 is missing a second
condition
foreign
so you're saying that the
business
representations
yeah so for them in these diagrams for
them to actually like fully be
equivalent you would essentially need to
pass the input through a linear layer
and so yeah that's something that's
important for them to be equivalent yeah
and if the input came from a neural
network and isn't the raw input then the
previous layer would count as this and
um but yeah I guess this this diagram
should be probably updated to have the
linear layer in there in the top right
um right so I guess I just looked at the
kind of the the weight of this layer
um typically a fully connected layer
will have both the weight and the bias
term
um and so if you if you actually include
that um that bias term right here you'll
have a plus b here and then if you break
that into B1 and B2 then you'll also
have a kind of a plus B1 and uh
um
actually sorry uh
I guess it'll still just B plus b but
yeah so essentially the the um
this is just trying to show the um the
bias terms essentially
okay um so additive and concatenation
are basically equivalent if you're kind
of
um if they are kind of prepended with
these linear layers
uh and so
it's not necessarily worth it's only the
takeaways don't try both of them because
it's uh you just need to try one of them
they'll be this give you probably the
same result
um another choice in terms of
conditioning is to use a multi-head
architecture where you have essentially
different output heads for the model and
this can be especially helpful if you
have different label spaces like one
label is continuous one label is
discrete and so forth
um
and uh another common choice is to use
multiplicative finishing so instead of
adding the output you actually multiply
the outputs or multiply the
representation of the task in an
element-wise fashion
now one thing you might be wondering is
well why would we why might we use
multiplicative conditioning
and there's a couple reasons for this uh
one is that it's going to be more
expressive per layer than additive
conditioning you can't represent this
sort of multiplicative conditioning in a
single layer if you're just doing
concatenation you can actually represent
it with multiple layers because of um
because neural networks can represent
any function
um
but it gives you more expressivity per
layer
um and if you also remember the
multiplicative gating that we talked
about before where you have these
different networks and you gate the
output this sort of conditioning can
represent that form of dating as well
and it allows you to actually
essentially dynamically choose which
parts of the network
um should be used for which tasks
um so essentially multiplicative
conditioning is a way that you can
generalize these independent networks as
well as independent heads
and so you can also represent multiple
head architectures with this
multiplicative gating
yeah so the question is are there cases
where you might apply different
conditioning to different layers
um
I guess the I mean the one answer is
that the design space is is very large
and you can choose to really do whatever
you want in the design space depending
on what you find works well
um I don't think that there's any
particular cases where it would be
especially helpful to have multiple
kinds of conditioning
um
but it's certainly kind of within the
design space of models
[Music]
I think that if you do it like at every
layer for example I would uh I think
it's strictly more expressive in that
sense
um
in the sense that the like you can
represent additive conditioning by
essentially having part of your input B
like all ones for example and then when
you do the multiplication then for that
all ones then you'll get uh basically
just concatenation
um so in that sense it's it's more
expressive if you have a high
dimensional enough input
um but it isn't necessarily like
strictly more expressive given the same
dimensionality yeah
so
important
yeah so after you pass this input the
uh so after you pass his input the
representation the test representation
through this linear Network you can
already think of that blue Vector in the
top right as a task representation
or a task embedding because it's
especially if you have a one-hot task
representation that you're passing as
input then
essentially the the weights or the
um the rows or something of that weight
Matrix or sorry The Columns of that
weight Matrix will essentially just be
an embedding of each of the tasks
um and then the way that you can get
condition on those different kinds of
embeddings
um
that's essentially what these different
choices correspond to
cool um so those are
I mean additive and multiplicative are
essentially the most basic choices of
conditioning there's also a lot more
complex choices so here are are some
examples of different kinds of
architectures that people have proposed
um
foreign
in general I think that wouldn't guard
when it comes to conditioning there
isn't really
um any like
specific like science for how to do it
um it's often very problem dependent uh
it's largely Guided by intuition and
knowledge about the problem
um and really more of an art than a
science
yeah absolutely so you can condition at
the very beginning condition later in
the network and so forth and the
multiplicative and additive conditioning
that we've talked about can all be
applied at different parts of the
network
um and in terms of like the intuition
that I'm talking about here
um maybe you have a problem where you'd
imagine that you want to process the
image differently for different tasks
and in that case earlier conditioning is
probably a better choice than later
conditioning
um and like I'm saying here it's usually
something that's quite problem dependent
and is usually based more on intuition
and what you find works on kind of
experimentation rather than any sort of
like science that will tell you exactly
what architecture to use
okay
cool
um
so that's it for the model architecture
for multitask learning
the next question is how we should form
the objective
and so we talked before about how we can
just use this sort of vanilla objective
of just adding up the tasks and
optimizing
but often we might want to weight
different tasks differently and we might
want to be able to define a weighted
objective where we apply a weight w in
front of the loss function and minimize
this weighted sum of the objectives
um and then of course the question comes
is like how do you choose this WI
does anyone have thoughts on how they
would go about choosing these weights
on
um
so would you have a higher weight for
larger data sets
smaller rates for a larger data sets
cool I guess on that note you may um
oftentimes the loss function you'll want
to for a Dave and task to want to
average it over the data set so that so
it's not larger for for larger data sets
and so forth but yeah that makes sense
uh in the back
okay
yeah so um the suggestion was based on a
paper on the website uh you can look at
the like what's called the heterosol
heteroskolastic uncertainty of the model
and use that to wait and wait
differently wait differently protect
that you're very certain about versus
tasks that you're less certain about
so look at the scales of the losses
themselves and if you notice that one
loss is on a higher scale then maybe you
weight it lower and vice versa yeah
thanks to film is high level
yes
yes you can have the weights themselves
be hyper parameters and and optimize
those hyper parameters
um in that case one question that comes
up is if their hyper parameter is what
objective are you optimizing for those
type of parameters um and so you do
eventually at some point need to have
some final objective even if you're
going to be optimizing the weights
themselves although you could optimize
them with respect to like the the
vanilla objectives for example
yeah
because
[Music]
yeah so you could have a curriculum and
maybe start have higher weights for
easier tasks at the beginning
I mean generally you'd want to weight
potassium you care about more with
better ways so if you have like a main
task and maybe some auxiliary tasks that
you're just doing to help along the
learning then you want to make those
lower yeah exactly so it's some of your
tasks you don't really care about that
much but you think that they might be
helpful as like a regularization or
something then you would want to wait
those lower than the main task is
yeah right so if you have a flux in the
tasks and some are more similar than
others then
um if you have a lot of a lot of class
that are very similar to each other and
some tasks that are very different then
you might want to wait the ones that are
different higher
um to kind of counter bound the tasks
that are more similar to each other
great so all of these are are really uh
any great answers to this question and
things that are good to do and when
choosing these weights
um and unfortunately like the model
architecture choosing these weights is
often more of an art as well and more
problem dependent and based on your
intuition
um and so you might try to manually
determine these based on importance or
priority or something that you know
about the kinds of tasks
um one thing that also came up is you
can also dynamically adjust these
throughout training in like a curriculum
or through other through other
strategies as well
um so I'll mention two things on this
slide there's already been like lots of
great ideas that have been mentioned but
um there are various heuristics for
trying to weight tasks one example is to
try to encourage gradients to have
similar magnitudes to try to help the
optimization problem
um and this would be an example of
something that's dynamic
and then one other example that I'd like
to bring up the next thing wasn't
brought up is to try to optimize for the
worst case task loss and
um this all isn't useful in all
scenarios but this is useful in
scenarios where
um you ultimately care about all of the
tasks and you want to make sure that all
of the tasks have are optimized
sufficiently well
so for example maybe different tasks
correspond to different people that are
using your service and you want to be
fair to all of them and you don't want
to have to have some users that are just
like the model is completely ignoring
and some users that it's really paying
attention to and this sort of worst case
task loss which um is kind of written in
this equation right here will
essentially try to optimized for the
worst case and try to make sure that the
the worst user is still being treated
well basically or has a good loss
function
so this is useful for fairness for
robustness
um and so forth
and so exactly what this equation means
is essentially you're going to be
picking the loss function with the
that has the highest loss currently and
optimize that one
actually optimizing this loss can be
pretty difficult if you have a lot of
tasks because you might need to
enumerate over all the possible tasks
and there are various kind of
approximations and approaches for trying
to optimize this function in a more
attractable way if you have a lot of
tasks
yeah so the um
what was that was another thing that you
can do is not just minimize losses but
also minimize the um the variance of the
losses as well so that they um that you
are kind of uh trying to get a similar
loss for all of the tasks I mean there
are some some scenarios where that sort
of thing will make sense other scenarios
where like for example if you have
auxiliary tasks this is probably a bad
idea because then you'll focus a lot on
the auxiliary tasks potentially more so
than the main task
s
talk about me
yeah
so this will lead to a non-stationary
optimization problem which I think is
what you're referring to and that can be
more tricky to optimize
[Music]
um
and in general people have found
sometimes found that subjective to be
difficult uh it does actually there are
examples of it working quite well
actually where you have different
domains and you're trying to optimize
for the worst case domain and people
have actually shown that this can
actually help robustness especially if
you think that maybe at test time your
distribution over tasks might be
changing then this will help you prepare
for that sort of distribution shift
um but it is certainly a more difficult
optimization problem and methods that
have used this have often introduced
things like regularization to help
stabilize it
great um so we've talked about the model
and we've talked about the objective uh
the last step is just how do we optimize
the objective optimize the model with
respect to the objective
so
um say we have our kind of vanilla
multitask objective
um really I'll go over kind of the basic
version of how we might optimize it
so we have a set of tasks and uh first
we can just sample a mini batch of those
tasks
um if we have if you only have a small
number of tasks then we can just sample
all the tasks
and then we'll sample a mini batch of
data points for each of the tasks that
we sampled
and so we'll run through the tests that
we sampled select training data for each
of those tasks
and then compute the loss on that mini
batch
so uh for each of the tasks that we
sampled for each of the mini batches
we'll evaluate how well the model is
performing on those data points
and then ultimately
uh compute the gradient of
that loss function and back propagate it
into the model's parameters to update
the parameters
so you can then apply your gradient with
your favorite Optimizer for neural
networks such as atom or maybe whatever
is the kind of the latest and greatest
thing
um this is fairly straightforward uh the
one thing that I think is is important
here is that it does especially if you
sample all tasks in step one this does
ensure that you're going to have
um you're going to potentially weight
the tasks evenly like even if you have a
lot more data from one task than another
task then this sort of approach will
make sure that you're kind of treating
them with equal weight
rather than based off of how much data
that they have so this is usually pretty
helpful
um
if you sample all of the tasks in step
one this is also doing stratification of
your batches meaning that you're going
to have an equal amount of data for
every single task in your batch and this
will lead to a lower variance gradient
than if you were to just randomly sample
data points especially if you have like
different loss functions for different
tasks so you'll have essentially in your
law function you'll have a component for
each task
um rather than just having the the
amount of rather than having it be
determined based on how you're sampling
foreign
and one thing that's pretty important
here also is for regression problems you
want to make sure that your labels are
on the same scale and so if you have a
regression problem where one problem
your labels are like range from zero to
two and another problem they range from
zero to a hundred that implicitly that's
going to upweigh the loss function for
the The Wider range labels and that
might not be what you want and so if you
instead normalize your label space then
that will ensure that you have kind of
equal weighting across the cast
okay um so in general there aren't um
this is a fairly typical way to optimize
the objective and there aren't too many
variations on this
um usually this isn't the usually this
isn't the hard part usually the harder
part is determining the architecture or
determining the um
uh or determining the objective to use
okay um a couple challenges that I that
I want to bring up
um basically what can go wrong when you
actually try to implement a multitask
Learning System
uh the first challenge is negative
transfer
and what I mean by this is that
sometimes
train the test independently works
better than training them together
uh this can be a bit unintuitive but um
this is referred to negative transfer in
the sense that
tasks some tasks are actually adversely
hurting the performance of other tasks
and so as a really concrete example of
this happening is if you take
um some somewhat recent approaches to a
version of a multitask version of cfar
and you evaluate these different
approaches essentially the the um the
first two approaches are multitask
learning approaches the third approach
is this more fancy architecture called
cross-stitch networks and the last row
is just independent training
uh what you'll notice here is that
um so these are different multi-head
architectures cross stitch architectures
and independent training what you'll
notice here is that independent training
is actually doing better than the
multitask learning approaches
uh and this is so an instance of
negative transfer it means that uh does
training on the task independently uh
and not sharing any weights is is better
in this case
now why might this happen um it could
happen for a number of reasons it could
be optimization challenges that are
coming up
um maybe the network is having trouble
finding kind of a solution that works
for all the tasks
um this could be caused by kind of
interference between the tasks between
the gradients of different tasks
tests might learn at different rates and
so maybe one task is actually a lot
easier and so maybe the loss function
will focus a lot on that easy task and
ignore the harder task and then once it
finds a good solution for the easy task
maybe it's already kind of reached a
part of the optimization space that's
really difficult for the harder tasks
um can also have to do with limited
representational capacity so multitask
networks often need to be a lot larger
than single task networks because you're
trying to do more
um so yeah these are a couple of reasons
for why you could see negative transfer
um so what do you do if you have
negative transfer
you can just share less you can move it
more towards independent training of
course there might be scenarios where
independent training is just the best
possible thing you can do
um
but there's a whole spectrum of what you
can do you can share fewer parameters
and it's also not just like a binary
decision of whether or not to share a
parameter or not there's also something
uh well so we talked about how you can
share
less parameters you could have fewer
shared parameters and more test specific
parameters but there's also something
called uh soft parameter sharing
and the way this works is you have
different networks for the different
tasks
and you essentially try to encourage the
weights to be similar to one another
uh and so while you're actually
representing the weights
completely independently you can
essentially add this top right term on
the right that encourages the parameters
to be similar and this will essentially
kind of tie that like bring them closer
to one another and constrain them in a
way that encourages them to be similar
in a softer way than like
hardly constraining them to be the same
yeah
um right so the I guess the the way that
the the second term is indexing onto the
tasks is with this with t Prime rather
than I and so it's just we're just using
a different index
um I guess oh yeah so T is actually
technically not defined so yeah that
should be
um that should be an eye rather than
yeah
um
that's a great question uh the
yeah so I guess I mean the short answer
is that a good way to detect negative
transfer is to train independent
networks and see if it's doing better
you don't need to necessarily trade
independent networks for all of the
Tufts so you could just trade it for
some of them and see if it's it's worse
uh
another way is if you have a sense for
what performance you want to get then
you could try to see a performance what
performance is relative to that but the
kind of the most sure way to detect this
sort of transfer is to train networks
independently
yeah
um
yeah that's an awesome question so the
question is is there a way to tell if
tasks will be synergistic or not
um I'll talk about that a bit in like
three slides uh it will be rather
unsatisfying but I'll talk about it a
bit in three sides yeah
right so that's a good question
um I think that I
right so I guess in this sort of soft
parameter sharing you do need to
represent the network separately and
represent the gradient separately and
this does make this sort of soft
parameter sharing approach much less
memory efficient it does require a lot
more memory
um and so if you're in scenarios where
you have or you need to train fairly
large networks this approach will be
kind of disadvantageous for that reason
um
and so I guess in terms of pros and cons
of this approach it allows more fluid
degrees of parameter sharing another uh
one con is that is essentially another
set of design choices and Hyper
parameters in terms of like how you
choose this sort of soft sharing and so
forth another downside is that it
requires a lot more memory than like
literally constraining the weights to be
the same
[Music]
yeah
um so the question is if you have a set
of tasks and maybe compared to
Independent training some of them
improve and some of them stay the same
and is there a way to detect essentially
which tasks are causing negative
transfer which tests are causing
positive transfer and so forth
um if you have a lot of compute uh one
way to do it is to try all like training
all combinations of tasks together and
that can usually give a pretty good
sense for which tasks are beneficial to
one another and which tasks are not
um in a few slides what I talk about
kind of task affinity and so forth
um I'll also mention approach that
allows you to
measure this in a less computationally
intensive way I won't go into some of
the details but I'll talk about it in a
little bit
um
[Music]
yeah so I think the question is kind of
referring to what I said here which is
that you may need a larger Network for
the multitasking and the question was
whether do you need does it need to be T
times larger than the single test
Network
um and uh typically it does not need to
be T times larger typically uh you the
network can represent things in a way
that
um
that can actually share capacity in some
ways
um and if it is T times larger then
oftentimes uh that's usually a bad sign
with regard to negative transfer and so
forth and you might actually be better
um trading networks separately uh
although even if you do make it t times
bigger there still might be the benefit
of better performance by um by training
them together
great so
the second challenge that I'll mention
is the opposite of negative transfer in
some ways which is
um over well sort of the opposite which
is maybe you're seeing overfitting maybe
you're seeing that it's fitting the
training data set well and it's not
fitting the test that well
uh and this could be in a scenario where
you may not be sharing enough
and the reason why I say this is that uh
multitask learning in many ways can be
viewed as a form of regularization
because it essentially gives you more
data
um if you have data sets for different
tasks or more or different labels for
different tasks and so forth
um
trading on different tasks is
essentially if can be viewed as a form
of regularization uh
not this is not always a good form of
regularization of course because you
might have negative transfer but
um if you are seeing overfitting sharing
more can be helpful because it can
essentially increase the amount of
regularization you have on your network
and so one possible solution to this is
to to try to share more
yeah
a number of costumes
um
yeah but the question is if one of the
tasks is easier and it learns very
quickly can that mess up the other tasks
and
um
I think it's I mean in many ways it's an
empirical question and I think that it
can depend on the scenario I've I think
that I've seen scenarios where it
doesn't
mess things up uh I also I think I've
also seen scenarios where it can
potentially mess things up I think it
many ways depends on that task if it
ends up learning very quickly and taking
a
a lot of the capacity of the network
then that can be a problem in some ways
um
in other cases maybe it's just really a
really easy task like maybe it just
needs to Output zero always and then it
might only be affecting like the last
layer like one part of the last layer
and not the entire network um and so
it's going to be fairly problem
dependent
okay and then the last challenge
um that'll bring up is what if you have
like a lot of tasks
um there's a question of should you
train all the tasks together which tasks
will be complementary
um relatedly if you have a task and you
have some potential auxiliary tasks how
do you know whether you should use those
auxiliary tasks or not and whether
they'll be helpful and it kind of
relates to the question of yeah will two
tasks be helpful for one another do we
know if we'll see negative transfer or
not should we train them together or not
um the bad news is that there's like no
kind of closed form solution that will
just like where you can like
take some data sets and tasks and it
will tell you the test similarity
um nothing like that really exists and
the reason for that is is actually that
test similarity and whether they'll have
a positive effect on optimization can
depend on a huge number of factors it
can depend on the architecture that
you're using
um what the model knows versus doesn't
know like the grasping example that I
gave on Monday if you want to grasp and
pour or grasp and click or something
then if the model knows how to grasp
then they're not going to be then they
might not be complementary at all
whereas they might be complementary if
you don't know how to grasp yet uh it
can depend on the optimizer that you're
using uh the step size that you're using
I can depend on like a whole host of
different factors and
this means that it's actually not just
going to depend on the data set and the
loss function itself
um and
I guess to illustrate kind of the the
reality of this is that actually one
paper from a couple years ago to kind of
to measure some sort of test similarity
what they proposed is literally to try
all combinations of trading tasks
together and use that to kind of look at
the performance of of all those
combinations which is obviously
combinatorially expensive and use that
as a way to measure test similarity
um the good news is that there are ways
to try to approximate cost similarity in
a way that isn't combinatorially
expensive and it actually will draw upon
some of the metal learning ideas that
we'll talk about later in the course but
um there are some ways to try to
approximate this sort of task similarity
and the way that it works is to try to
First Trade all the tasks together in a
single multitask Network then analyze
the statistics of that optimization run
to compute some some approximate measure
of task affinity and then once you have
those task affinities from that single
training run you can use that to group
tasks together or do something else with
it
um
yeah and this is um something like this
is going to be a lot more efficient than
trying to try all possible combinations
of training tasks together it's still
somewhat dissatisfying because you still
need to do one full training run of
training all the tasks together uh but
it's at least a bit more satisfying than
the combinatorial solution and it seems
quite natural to me that you would still
require something like a full trading
run because the fact that task
similarity can depend on all these
factors including optimization factors
okay um so I'm not going to go into the
details of this but if anyone is
interested in learning more about it
there's a a reference to the paper I'm
also happy to chat about it more in
office hours if people are interested as
well
okay um so to recap multitask learning
uh today we defined a task as these data
generating distributions and a loss
function which can be used to sample a
train set in a test set
uh we talked about model architectures
and how we might have used
multiplicative conditioning or additive
conditioning on our task descriptor
and we might want to share more or less
based on the kind of transfer that we
observe from training
we also talked about the objective and
the optimization process such as kind of
this this weighted objective and
different ways to choose weights
as well as trying to use stratified mini
batches to reduce the variance of the
optimization process
great um so any questions on on
multitask learning before I move to kind
of a case study of using multitask
learning in the real world problem
cool okay
so uh
I'm gonna we're gonna go over the case
study from this particular paper and the
goal of this is uh essentially to build
a recommender system for YouTube
we want to be able to recommend people
videos to watch
and
um we want to be able to make good
recommendations for YouTube and in
particular we want to be able to
recommend videos on the right column
this is a figure from the paper uh you
want to be able to kind of rank and then
choose videos that would be good to show
to the user in the right column
okay
um and why is this a multitask learning
problem
um
the reason is that there's going to be a
few conflicting objectives that we are
going to try to use when making
recommendations
um and by we I mean the authors of this
paper they chose a few different
objectives that they care about one is
videos that people might rate highly
another is that videos that users will
share with other people
uh and another is videos that the user
will actually watch
um and these are
in my opinion fairly reasonable things
that you might want to be able to uh
optimize
and uh there's also this sort of
implicit bias that's caused by feedback
um the user may have watched something
because it was recommended by the system
uh and so this is something that's super
important to be aware of in general
um although it's not something that it's
something that this paper acknowledges
but not something that they necessarily
solve
okay so the way that they set it up is
the input is what the user is currently
watching as well as some features about
the user
um this could include their history of
things that they've learned before
they've watched before
um or maybe interest that they entered
into this into YouTube or something like
that
uh they generate a few hundred candidate
videos
and then they want to be able to rank
these videos
and ultimately the ones that are at the
top of the rank will be ones that they
will want to recommend
so serve the the top ranking videos to
the user
um and so in terms of generating the
candidates they pull videos from
multiple candidate generation algorithms
uh and this isn't really the focus of
the paper but for generating these
candidates they consider things like
matching the topic of the video that the
user was currently watching
um also looking at videos that are most
frequently watched when people watch the
query video and other things like that
and then kind of the main part of this
paper is thinking about given all these
candidates can you rank these candidates
and pick the predict the ones that will
um
kind of yeah rank them and prioritize
the videos that you might want to show
to user from these candidates
okay um and so
the input here is uh the query video
um the candid video so once they have
their list of candidates they're going
to pass those candidates into their
Network to try to predict
um to try to predict uh the engagement
and satisfaction with that candid video
and so uh the inputs are the the query
video the candidate video as well as
features about the user in context
um these are passed in as inputs to the
neural network and they're embedded into
the neural network
and then we're going to be trying to
predict engagement and satisfaction
um engagement is uh can correspond to a
few different things and correspond to
Binary classification tasks like whether
they're going to click on the video
it can correspond to regression tests
which might be like how long they spent
watching that candid video
um and satisfaction will be uh could be
things like clicking the like button so
this would be a binary classification
task and uh it can also be a regression
test such as like if they're given a
survey like how do they rate the video
okay and then
um
once the the model predicts engagement
and satisfaction they use some weighted
combination of these two uh predictions
to produce a score for the ranking
um and this the weights for this uh were
like manually tuned essentially uh
by the um
by the authors or someone else
okay um I guess one question for you uh
do you feel like these objectives are
reasonable or do you think that there
are issues that might come up
do you think they're good
yes
um
yeah so um for time spent uh the that's
a good suggestion if you have a really
long video they might spend more time
watching it if you have a short video
they will naturally they can't spend a
long time watching it yeah
yeah so these metrics aren't necessarily
including whether or not the user
comments um and you could look at like
the sentiment of the comments for
example as an additional metric to
predict yeah
um
I don't think I don't know if there is a
dislike is there just like okay maybe
they also so they might also have binary
Publications
um but that seems like a good thing to
include yeah
yeah
exactly so a lot of these things that
might depend on the user and this might
be pretty challenging using the user
features might hopefully be helpful for
that but
um at the same time it's something
that's important to keep in mind
yeah
oh
I mean this is more of like a strategy
thing for YouTube but YouTube's foreign
yeah so if you want to maximize Revenue
then you might want to consider whether
the candidate video has ads or not
any other thoughts
one other thing that I'll that I'll add
that
um kind of surprised that no one
mentioned but maybe we don't want
YouTube to be maximizing time spent or
something maybe spending a lot of time
on YouTube maybe maybe it's a good thing
for Google maybe it's not necessarily
the best thing for their users
um or maybe uh yeah in general
keeping in mind um yeah what's good in
the grander scheme of things compared to
maximizing revenue is usually something
that's good not just for long-term
revenue of course but also in terms of
people's well-being and so forth as well
okay
so um that's the setup of the problem
um for the architecture they use what
they call a shared bottom model uh I
think this is more commonly used more
commonly referred to as a multi-head
architecture so it looks something like
this where
they have the input features and then
they pass this in through kind of a
shared shared layers and then those are
passed through the different heads of
the model that are independent
um
yeah and this can
um the sort of architecture can
potentially harm learning when the
correlation between tests is low
um but they found it to work well in in
this setting
oh sorry
this is I think sorry this is the first
thing that they tried and they found
that it actually it did harm learning
when the correlation between tasks was
difficult and so it was low and so they
um they actually didn't use uh well I
think they did evaluate this multi-head
architecture but they didn't use this
multi-head architecture in their kind of
main experiments
uh what they found to be helpful is to
do a form of soft parameter sharing and
they referred to this as a multi-gate
mixture of experts where they
essentially have these different modules
these different experts and then they
um based on kind of features from the
shared layers at the bottom they will
gate the kind of which experts they're
using for which tasks
um and they're going to gate in the way
that's actually dependent on the input
and this means that maybe for some users
you might have some modules being used
or some kinds of videos you might have
some modules being used and so forth
um so I guess getting back to one of the
questions earlier this is actually a way
to allow the network to sort of
dynamically choose what is being used
for which tasks and and which users as
well
um I don't have time really to go
through this but there's kind of a few
more details on exactly how this is
implemented where you essentially
um
to have the different
um you're trying to basically decide
which expert to use for a given input
and the given task and you can you do
the gating through this sort of
multiplicative interaction and then once
you choose the experts that you're using
you sum over the kind of the weighted
outputs
um and then once you once you have the
output of that module there's also some
of these task specific neural networks
that are the heads of the network
okay
um and then they implemented this in
tensorflow which isn't too surprising on
tpus uh they trained it
um in temporal order and so they get
data in a stream and they train they run
ramp training continuously always
consuming the most recent data
uh
and they evaluated uh offline AUC and
squared error metrics in terms of like
their ability to predict clicks their
ability to predict whether or not a user
would rate something or like something
and then they also did online a b
testing uh
um in comparison to the system that's in
production
and these were live metrics that were
looking at the time spent survey
responses and the rate of dismissals
uh and one thing that um that's
especially important in this application
is computational efficiency uh they have
a ton of data and
um and you want to be able to actually
evaluate this model quickly as well
okay
um so the results uh are from the live a
b tests are here and so they are
evaluating the
um the multi-head architecture the the
more basic architecture as well as the
mixture of experts with either four
experts or eight experts
and
um it's a bit small but what you can see
here is
um in comparison to the production
system they see a
and both an improvement in both
engagement as well as satisfaction of
about
0.45 and uh three percent for those two
metrics respectively with the the eight
mixture of experts model
um so this is in my opinion pretty
impressive because I would have guessed
that the production system is pretty
good uh at recommending videos
and if you can also actually visualize
how it's used utilizing experts for
different tasks and you see that for
some tasks it's utilizing some experts
and for other tasks that is choosing to
utilize other experts
um
and uh
so it's kind of interesting to look at
these kinds of visualizations and
visualizations like this can also give
you a sense for task Affinity
um after you train the network on all
the tasks of course
um and then one of the details that they
mentioned is that they found that there
was actually in some of their training
runs sometimes the gates would just like
polarize and would be um
uh would it would choose us to use like
only one expert for example for a task
and they found that it was pretty
important to use Dropout on the experts
to encourage it to not like choose just
one expert from one task and so forth
um and uh yeah they found that to be
helpful to improve training stability
there